[Music]
global events X onslaught is the final
global event to be introduced to the
division and it's due to be released
sometime in May this is just a quick
video outlining what we know so far the
modifiers for onslaught are onslaught
del Boone bleed and gas effects two
enemies in addition to normal damage
reload to change the effect this is the
global modifier so it's always active
elemental damage is applied to your
weapon and when you reload the damage
type changes the elemental damage is
applied to your primary secondary and
sidearm weapon separately so it's
possible to have a different element
type applied to each webinar savage
onslaught onslaught behavior enemies are
vulnerable to one effect type and
resistant to others agents take
increased damage from resistant enemies
the activity modifier only available to
be activated in the Cee playlist this is
where the global modifier really starts
to matter all enemies have an element
type attached to them having a matching
damage type equipped will have them
gunned down quickly on top of us enemies
with resistance to your current damage
type will deal considerably more damage
to you and brutal onslaught savage
onslaught behavior plus when two or more
group members kill a vulnerable enemy
within two seconds each member can
reload to gain damage bonus for a single
clip the group modifier lacked the
activity modifier can only be activated
in the set GE playlist this is where
good communication comes in with this
saucy little number you can gain a
damage buff on your next clip that will
ignore element types the bonus is
represented by a skull that appears next
to your weapon this bonus is weapons
specific and will disappear as soon as
you reload that weapon or the magazine
is empty the mission playlist for this
global event is Warren gate power plant
police academy Broadway Emporium Russian
consulate and stolen signal as the
incursion the classified sets available
are predators muck fire crest Lone Star
and reclaimer
as per usual there are three new masks
with this global event there are nothing
to get excited about like the blackout
masks these are just risk ins of
existing masks I'm unsure of the
commendations for onslaught at the stage
they weren't included in the pts and the
only information I could find was dated
and in some cases tied to the event
leaderboard which will definitely be
changed in order to be successful in
this global event on the moist streets
of wintertime New York there are a
couple of things that need to be
considered you need to reload to change
a damaged type and the NPC's will be
doing more damage reload speed is a must
with the activity and group modifiers
you'll be reloading a lot in order to
have the right damage element selected
lower the time and frustration by
rolling reload speed onto your holster
this can always be rear old back after
the event look at your weapon mods you
can get additional reload speed on your
groups and magazines communicate with
your team the sort of thing goes without
saying with any content but in this
global event if you can take full
advantage of the group modifier you'll
have a much easier time also you may
find that assigning an element type to
each group member works a little better
for you so snuggle up and make a plan
before starting each mission these are
the three sets I'll be taking into this
global event but I certainly don't think
these are the only options predators
mark for its 20% reload speed bonus but
also because of the damage er can
continue to do while sitting in cover
switching between element types
strikers enemies with different element
types can take very little damage and
this makes it crazy easy to maintain max
stacks which in turn will help keep your
healing up and of course d3 to soak up
that increased damage coming at you and
your team
Lonestar could also play an important
role but I really didn't get a chance to
test this out
the gameplay used in this video wasn't
my own a member from the community
kindly allowed me to use this as I
hadn't recorded any of my own from the
PGS if you'd like to watch the full
gameplay i've included a link down below
there are a couple that run a small
channel called not them gaming their
videos are informative the cutest [ __ ]
and are genuinely nice people if you get
a chance check them out speaking of
community you may have noticed a few
strange words pop up through the video
these words were suggested by some of
the Indian discord community as a
challenge for my next video work well
this video they're a weird bunch but
that's why I like them if you're a
player looking for a friendly place to
hang out and would like to group up with
like-minded gamers I've left a link to
the discord server below anyway
hopefully you've gained a little bit of
information for the upcoming global
event any further questions just let me
know
Cheers
[Music]
y'all know my just proc didn't it I saw
that sure the mute or something and then
a lot of a fork sake
[Music]